each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright so good afternoon everyone for
those micro coil and drummer for the
summer working under Ralph perfect
script the online services in
advertising group and my advisor
professor richard home from the earth of
Colorado is here to talk about some work
that we've done on a project called
social fusion thanks Mike well glad to
be here this is a topic that I'm going
to be talking problem primarily but I
sort of high-level we don't have a
implementation yet of everything and so
it's more sort of a sort of the
futuristic direction that we've been
exploring and it's all about trying to
fuse together mobile sensor and social
information to help sort of enable next
generation context awareness and this is
work with a bunch of PhD students
including Mike and some some faculty as
well my background is primarily in
mobile systems and why are the sensor
networks and we have been noticing of
course in mobile and sensor networks a
huge surge in popularity on these types
of systems and in parallel also a rise
in popularity for social networks and we
think that all three of these are going
to give rise to a much richer
environment of context awareness where
applications can be customized much more
precisely than they are now to to your
you know to what what you're interested
in and there has been some work in the
past on context awareness certainly in
the 90s and even now in ubiquitous
computing but much of that earlier work
came before the advent of these major
trends so social networks weren't really
around in the 90s Mobile smartphones
have just really seen a big you know
growth since
the iphone was introduced in 2007 and
sensor networks of course as an area
that I like wireless sensor networks
have sort of just the last decade have
really grown in popularity at least in
the research community and so all three
of these trends are are rich sort of
veins to mine for for context so for
example social networks provide you two
classes of information that describe who
you are basically you know what my what
my likes are you know what my hobbies
are you know my favorite bands my
favorite movies all these preferences
are listed on a lot of our profiles as
well as who am i friends with so sort of
two different classes of information
there and this they describe a lot about
Who I am mobile networks there's been a
lot of work on location-aware
applications where they use your GPS or
some other Wi-Fi localization whatever
technology to tell you where you are but
actually there recently there's been
even more work trying to mine the
additional sensors that we have on these
mobile smart phones to give you even
further context and so for example some
work out at Dartmouth that has the
looking activity recognition by looking
at accelerometer information listening
to the microphone trying to infer what
activity you're actually currently in or
undergoing and that's additional context
information that may be helpful and then
of course sensor networks provide
information about the ambient
environment with the lights on you know
you know who might be in the room that
kind of thing and of course i'm here at
microsoft i just got back from the
microsoft faculty summit about a week or
two ago and there's a lot of you know
justifiable sort of i think pride in
sort of the connect and this is a very
rich multimedia sensor at least i would
characterize it as that and so that
provides additional contextual
information so sensor networks are not
just these small mote class devices but
can also be
quite quite complex we think all of
these are driving us towards sort of
this vision of context-aware computing
where the cloud which is a fourth major
trend that's happening at the same time
in parallel will be where we do all the
fusion of these different streams out of
this fusion we're going to be getting a
whole new class of sort of i think
context where applications how many of
you have seen Minority Report okay so
everybody pretty much everybody here so
there are different there's a there's a
there's a part of it whereas Tom Cruise
is walking through the mall the the mall
census who he is sort of knows a little
bit about him and starts to project you
know in this case an ad on you know the
screen saying hello Tom you know and and
so it's customized to him and the
multimedia environment instantly sort of
morphs to what he's interested in if you
think that this is a little too creepy
than or too intrusive there are I think
other classes of context where
applications such as mobile health you
know if I walk into a supermarket can I
be informed because i have an allergies
against peanuts that i should definitely
not buy this product even though it
doesn't say on its ingredient list that
it has peanuts you know so we can
certainly develop tailored mobile health
applications as well that are in this
case very context aware about our
individual sort of health situation
we've also all heard about some of these
mobile social networks these are in sort
of a class so those are sort of
individually customized or tailored
context where apps we also have are
starting to see the emergence of sort of
group based sort of context where apps
and mobile social networks are one
example foursquare facebook is added you
know location features as has twitter
etc and so certainly there you can you
know see where you're nearby friends and
that
kind of thing but we think there's
actually a whole new class of
context-aware apps that are interesting
to explore from a research perspective
and I'll talk a little bit about mobile
social video mobile social audio and
mobile social brainstorming that we've
been sort of playing around with in our
group and we're using this sort of to
try to explore different pieces of that
social fusion vision and so essentially
our social fusion project is to try to
you know figure out what this cloud in
the center is and try to sort of make
some progress on on building out some of
that infrastructure and so based on our
experience playing with different apps
that are mobile social and all that this
is what we envisioned to be what makes
sense to us at least so we're gonna have
different information streams largely
social sensor and mobile and they're
going to be sort of gathered and
collected in some sort of database it
doesn't have to be sort of a centralized
piece but it could be very much
distributed and on top of this will have
a sort of class of sort of inference or
data mining that's going on and this is
actually could be composed of multiple
sub layers so for example there's been
some work on inference of like affective
computing where you're trying to
determine the mood or the emotion of
people and so you may be taking into
account lots of different streams and
making sort of a first layer inference
you know here's a face here's a nose
here's a tone of a voice and then a
second layer of inference built on top
of those first layers that are
ultimately determining maybe the mood of
the person and then that is used later
on in what we would call sort of our
recommendation or actuation layer where
we actually do something with that
information we we play a video or some
some audio stream or we turn on the
lights where we change the ambient
heating that kind of thing so really
just the three layers and and inside of
each one of them really multiple
sub-layers sort of compose
web services together okay one of the
concerns that has arisen in our initial
investigation here is that privacy's of
course a big issue that's a question we
all we always get and really what we're
sort of drawing here is that we're
probably going to need privacy filters
throughout this architecture for all of
the major substrings here and so the
aspects that we've been exploring we
have it as I said built out this whole
version we've been exploring individual
pieces of this so we've been primarily
looking at the mobile and the social
pieces so far and even though i come
from a sensor networks background we
haven't strongly enter twine sensor
networks yet into some of our research
we've been looking at privacy issues but
only in the context of the single
information stream for social networks
but of course we would like to expand to
other sort of privacy streams certainly
there's been work on sort of
location-aware privacy a lot of work has
been done to sort of sort of mask your
location and we've also been as you'll
see we played around with some of the
data mining inference and recommendation
just to sort of get a feel for what this
might look like ok so if we examine each
one of the individual streams we already
see progress people focusing just on
social for example so whole new class of
socially informed applications is
emerging with increasing integration of
Facebook and Twitter into their online
and mobile apps so you can easily sort
of say for example you can post to your
facebook that you account that you like
this news article something like that
and of course Microsoft and Google are
going one step beyond that they're
making search more social and I think
news more social Mike what mike tells me
is correct as well and I'll describe
briefly some some work that we've been
doing a Colorado on
so social news and then also describe
the work on context awareness that where
we sort of prototype to mobile social
jukebox or mobile social audio mobile
social video and mobile social
whiteboard okay so that's sort of if
you're just looking at the social stream
how you can sort of enhance applications
by just using social information you can
certainly enhance applications by just
using mobile information as well and
there's been progress in that regard as
well well what essentially people do is
take advantage of the different sensors
on the phone to enhance their
applications we already know about
location-aware applications we see them
all the time more recently augmented
reality apps have been appearing like
layer browser and yelp monocle whereas
you sort of orient yourselves you can
see an overlay on reality of some
additional sort of tags that describe
what you're looking at and so these are
orientation aware accelerometers are
being used as well for games and then
mobile video apps are increasingly more
prevalent like apple's facetime that can
use the front end or the back cameras
for your you know mobile phone and then
you know of course it's only a matter of
time before we start using some of the
other sensors like light and proximity
as well and as I mentioned earlier some
people are starting to combine and use
multiple multi-dimensional sort of
sensor data to infer activity okay and
then the final stream is sort of the
just the sensors themselves fixed sensor
networks you know this is a rich set of
applications and they can provide
information about you know whether the
lights on in the room contextual simple
contextual clues like that and all the
way up to more can sort of advanced
emotional sort of inferences and so
camera networks for example
and as part of that connect is as part
of this new wave of really complex
sensors okay so social fusion is about
fusing all three of these major streams
some of the early work mobile social
networks kind of misses out on sort of
fixed sensor networks and what they can
do and so I don't think it has fully
realized the potential of of context
awareness here and so it's up to us to
really explore this area and and maybe
invent the next killer mobile sensor
social app it starts to become a
mouthful there but I'm actually thinking
that you know as the systems researcher
I kind of like building infrastructure
and protocols and I'm thinking that this
might be the case it was like we're in
the early 80s of the Internet where
they're building oh they built a lot of
infrastructure IP routing TCP HTTP you
know dns whatever well it's not HTTP but
but like dns and so some of the early
infrastructure that will enable sort of
sort of next generation killer apps
there and so I'm kind of excited about
some of this infrastructure stuff okay
so then let's look at some of the apps
that we prototyped I'm not going to get
into a lot of detail here but you know
mobile social music jukebox so the idea
is that if you walk into a bar with your
friends the bar recognizes who you are
can go look at your facebook profiles
for hints about what you like and then
synthesize a music playlist based on
that kind of information and so it's
mobile in the sense that it knows who
you know where you are in this case
through by detecting your mobile
location and this can be accomplished in
a variety of different ways I think in
our prototype we use bluetooth but I
mean you can use a check-in model you
can use sort of publishing your location
periodically on Facebook something like
that we also need a handle to who you
are which will allow us then to
retrieve information about you through
the Facebook API we are primarily
playing with Facebook but we could say
with twitter as well a facebook is
convenient and then we would synthesize
sort of that information and then go out
to maybe a pay service a web two point
oh whatever service to retrieve a
playlist okay but we actually probably
have to do some additional thinking here
because if we have multiple people in
the room we have to figure out how to
fuse together their different interests
to come up with a playlist that sort of
most pleases I guess the group and so
that's actually some of some interesting
things that we stumbled on to when we
were trying to build this mobile social
jukebox if you will the first if I'm the
only person in the room and I haven't
given access to any of my mp3 library
I've only given you access to my my
social profile which might list some
bands that i like but might not might
list that i like hiking and biking and
you know Shakespeare let's say so how
does that if I list hiking biking and
Shakespeare how can i generate a music
playlist from that I mean it's not
necessarily obvious you know from that
and so how do we generate a playlist for
a single person is one challenge then if
there are multiple people in the room
how do we how do we reconcile their
potentially conflicting interests if one
person likes classical another person
likes you know hip-hop how do we combine
those so so these are all sort of
subjective and in fact a lot of this
context awareness starts to come you
have to sort of very much start doing
with many human studies I'll talk a
little bit about that later well so
that's them that's a mobile social a
music app here's a mobile social video
app that that actually mic built call
social where flicks it's doing the same
thing so the architecture looks very
similar you know when you walk into a
room if you've got a video
or screen it automatically adapts its
content to you okay and so will play you
what you want to see and so this might
be interesting like for an example in a
sports bar where you and your buddies
arrive and you want to see the game and
you park yourself in front of a you know
a screen it automatically senses that
you're all fans of I don't know
Manchester United or Chelsea you know
and so it'll automatically switch to the
game that you're interested in you know
and so this is what we were trying to
prototype with social where flicks in
this case we were trying to show a video
that all up sorry a movie that all of
them might be interested in watching
together and so again we are using
social information mobile information
and some back end web services in this
case the netflix movie recommender okay
so i've already sort of gone through
this architecture picture so i'll just
skip this ok so we face challenges as i
said in terms of just the context-aware
part how do we how do we generate you
know these playlists arm so for example
this illustrates some of the issues if
on my facebook profile I listed that I
like matrix revolutions and mission
impossible this can be used as input
into the netflix movie recommender which
might come back with you know a set for
each one of my favorites that I've
listed recommended movies to watch so
then there's a question of well for a
single individual then all right we can
sort of put all these together what
metric do we use to reorder these to
show the movie that would be most
pleasing to that individual do we use
sort of release date to show the most
recent movies that they may not have
seen or do we show you know the the star
rating the highest rated movies first we
don't know so just for an individual
starts to become kind of interesting and
even hear how you fuse together from
each one of the individual favorites
you're sort of aggregate list starts to
become kind of an interesting question
you may for example want to preserve
diversity and so instead of sort of
fusing them all together you might say I
want to keep a couple from each one of
the original favorites and have that
sort of propagate through to the end if
you will and so that's just the problems
that we face when we have a single user
and then we ran into the problem because
it's a social aware flicks app how do we
do this for multiple people so assuming
that we've solved all those problems for
a single individual now we have Mike and
Fred and they've all they can all
generate sort of recommendations for
each one of them but now Mike and Fred
we want to analyze sort of how do we
come up with a group recommendation that
would most please Mike and Fred together
and so there are different ways that we
can do this one way is just to sort of
look at let's say for example the
highest rated movies in Mike's list and
the highest rated movies and Fred's list
and only take those and present that as
the playlist but another way is to sort
of analyze the content of those of those
favorite movies so the first approach
doesn't even look at sort of a content
and says you know Mike actually likes a
lot of comedy movies as does Fred and so
this might be something that we can
glean from doing some more deep data
analysis and therefore comedies is the
dominant theme and so we're going to
recommend comedy films in the final
aggregate ok so this is some of the
things that we ran into when we were
trying to prototype the social web
flicks I can't say that we have you know
great answers to any of these
problems these are just more like
questions that we ran into and this work
actually helps stimulate when I'm going
to talk about next which is our group
paper from 2010 on enhancing group
recommendation by incorporating social
relationship interactions so the prior
work on social where flicks didn't
really take into account it was only
weakly social because it was looking at
things like oh you know we're looking at
the content of people's favorites and so
we were only looking at you know comedy
films you know we extracted that
information but we didn't know whether
Mike and Fred were good friends or not
or whether they were like siblings or or
what you know and so we didn't have any
sense of the social relationship between
these folks and so we thought that would
be really interesting to investigate the
how social influence and the
relationship between the different group
members are they all strangers that are
meeting for the first time or are their
husband wife couple or you know some
friends or getting together on Saturday
night you know how can we sort of use
these indicators to help us give a
better group recommendation and so what
I'm showing here is essentially sort of
what we were investigating and so a lot
of work has gone on on individual
recommender systems and so we're we're
fine with leveraging some of that and
what are what our contribution or
interest was in was the consensus
function how do you fuse together and
decide on a group recommendation when
you have all these individual
recommendations and our idea was to use
group social group descriptors
indicators of the ties between the
different members of the group and and
so are you know so we embarked on trying
to understand what this kind of
consensus fusion function or ensemble
function would be and I feel that you
know we did make some progress though by
no means
you know did we answer all the nail down
all the questions but we had the under
we had actually you know interview
people yeah and we're systems folks in
so we're not necessarily the best at
doing user studies so take what I'm
about to show you with a grain of salt
but we did extract some interesting
trends and so let me describe sort of
what what we found there has been prior
work on group decision-making
investigating that and roughly speaking
the kinds of group decision strategies
that have been uncovered our average
satisfaction minimum misery and maximum
satisfaction so the way that this would
work is if Tom and Mike are both have
individually sort of raided a movie like
let's see three and five for Tom and
Mike for the matrix if the average
satisfaction approach holds then you
would average these and you would
predict that the group would when they
got together and they talked about the
movie that they would come out with a
sort of yeah you know maybe Mike's might
go down a little bit and Thomas might go
up a little bit and so this is average
satisfaction minimum misery is when if
they get together and they talk about it
they decide yeah you know that really
was a terrible movie you know and so
they tend to go towards the most
negative and then maximum satisfaction
would be when they tend to bias their
their group a decision towards the most
positive okay we actually found
indications of all three kinds oh and it
depended on how social the group was and
so you can't just apply those previous
group decision strategies on a blanket
way it sort of depends on these more
fine-grained contextual clues that we've
been trying to extract so for example so
one of our contributions we came up with
a social descriptor this is basically
trying to measure
how strongly connected are the people in
the group to each other I'm not going to
get into too many of the details here
and we also have an expertise descriptor
that's trying to measure you know if one
person in a group is much you know has
much more expertise maybe they've
watched a thousand movies and so in
certain situations people may be willing
to defer to the leader if you will so
there's sort of this leader syndrome
that's also been investigated and that's
partially reflected in this expertise
descriptor there has been early work on
also looking just that content where
people look at sort of how similar are
the content interests of that have been
expressed between all of these different
folks this is called average pairwise
dissimilarity and variance disciplinary
and so what we do is we eventually this
is these are not really looking at
things like what's social you know how
strongly connected are these people so
we will compare to this a little bit
later on and so what we found these are
just sort of trends and this kind of
illustrates what happens I don't think
these were actual numbers but that if
the social tie was let's say between a
husband and a wife so that's a pretty
strong social tie so maybe lets a user
once the husband user to is the wife we
found that the in our interviews at
least the eventual consensus that they
came to in rating was the maximum
satisfaction okay and I think that was
because they were sort of deferring to
each other you know and and sort of you
know getting along with each other it's
very important so so a husband and wife
very tightly coupled we got that
information or we got that kind of
behavior when friends who are more
loosely coupled we got a sort of an
averaging effect and then when strangers
were together we got through this
minimum misery sort of effect so
depending on how strong the social
relationship was you have sort of
different you would you would you would
use a different policy for grouper
and we also we measured expertise and
similarity as well and for expertise
it's sort of behaved kind of like I
don't know how you would even describe
the expertise how would you describe
that Mike is that more like a maximum I
guess it was if this user one is the
expert and user to the non-expert then
the group tends to follow the experts
advice okay so given all of this sort of
this this interview sort of data we went
ahead and created a function and this is
sort of this scary function but all it's
really doing and saying if our social
strength is really strong then people
behave with sort of a max satisfaction
this is the husband and wife situation
if your friends then you sort of do an
averaging and if you're strangers then
you wind up your behavior would be your
group consensus behavior would be
towards the minimum kind of thing and
then you would sort of have the way we
incorporate expertise in here is to
modify the individual rankings of
viewers multiply it by the expertise of
that person okay and so and so I can't
remember exactly how we incorporate the
dissimilarity so anyway these this was a
heuristic that fit our data well but we
also wanted a more general sort of way
than the heuristic to figure out in any
general sort of case can we sort of
derived rules and so we came up with a
more systematic approach using
associative classification and an
example of that is we're essentially
looking for frequent itemsets or
patterns in the data so it could be the
case so we were using the FP growth
algorithm and so it could be the case
for example that you notice that every
time
the social strength is strong and the
max rating is for that the group rating
winds up being four and so you would
extract this rule from the data that you
would get from like user studies that
kind of thing and so this is a more
systematic way to sort of derive sort of
rules it's more probabilistic if you
will and we went ahead and then
subjected you know after we had we had
interviewed all this we went to we went
and evaluated and looked at the
performance of our systems and so we had
just about 30 people that we were
interviewing to get sort of the ground
truth on this and this graph is really
just showing is just quantifying sort of
that when you have a strong social
strength between a couple you the best
approach was maximum satisfaction when
you have medium sort of social strength
the best approach seem to be average
satisfaction and when you had almost
very first acquaintance strangers the
best function seemed to be a minimum
misery function so ultimately at the end
of the day we wanted to compare our
recommendations both for the heuristic
and for the more systematic FP growth
approach to the state of the art which
was not using any social it was using
the the pairwise to similarity metric
okay and so the pairwise dissimilarity
approach so we were looking at sort of
the number of stars in the movie that
was recommended and how different that
was from the group consensus the ground
truth and so the mean difference for
average pairwise the similarity was
about point eight seven but you see that
we have a lower number of sort of were
closer to the truth by using heuristics
and sort of in between it's a rule based
approach and based on our under system
at accrual-based approach would do
better and we think the reason is
because the rule based approach actually
needs a lot more data to build the rules
properly and so we only had about 30
people's worth of data so we think that
over time the rule based approach will
will be better in any case both were an
improvement upon the baseline which was
what we considered the state of the art
okay so this gives you a sense of you
know how difficult you know there's a
lot of effort that's that's when you're
trying to do context-aware research you
got to interview people and do things
which might take you outside of your
comfort zone okay all right so I'll just
skip this another context were app that
we looked at was wiki Walker which was a
mobile social whiteboard and the idea
here is that you would combine together
again your location and social
networking information when you are
standing in front of a white board you
know and most of the time when you're in
front of a white board the goal is to
brainstorm you want to come up with new
ideas for research a new new project for
your class that kind of thing oh and we
thought wouldn't it be great if the
white board could suggest ideas to
brainstorm or on based on information
about you so if you're interested in
hiking or if you're into have expertise
in security it can actually pull that
doesn't have to be from facebook of you
your linkedin a professional profile or
it could be if it knows what your name
is can look at your author lists and
that kind of thing and so pull
information that would then recommend
ideas to brainstorm off of and again
this is mobile and social so and we
actually we presented this at a at a
workshop at at the group conference okay
and so the final a context were app that
I wanted to mention was social news and
I know some folks here at Microsoft are
are exploring this topic as well and so
the idea here is
you know we're not playing with the
entire social fusion architecture the
pieces that we're touching on this
particular project are sort of this part
of the cloud as well as just just the
facebook data stream and so the idea
that we were looking at was how to
improve social news recommendations
google news and and big news all sort of
provide a list of recommendations and
use you know advanced algorithms to try
to to give you a good news topics
palabra filtering other types of
recommendation but we thought we could
actually improve upon this by leveraging
social information and that includes the
personal interests also interest about
who your friends are that kind of thing
so somewhat similar and motivated by
some of our earlier group work so we
think that we can add some set a subset
of Newt to the to the current news
recommendations things that are of
course based on your personal interests
derived from your facebook likes but
also may be derived from we saw social
strength earlier you know this was the
example that we that we were sort of
bringing up we might care about what's
going on where my wife or where my eye
my husband or my parents live okay and
we can find that from facebook profile
information if people fill it out and
and so the idea was that we might care
about you know what kinds of stories are
affecting you know them back at home you
know or if it knew where my hometown was
it might provides you know some
recommendations for stories from my
hometown that I would be interested in
that kind of thing and this can be mined
from you know your your social network
information and then we thought another
class might be we might like to see
stories from recommend news from our
most similar friends maybe our buddies
that we go
climbing with that kind of thing so this
is a sketch of the architecture that
we've been working on for social news
it's essentially taking three streams
the first we're essentially taking
information from Facebook over here
we're mining that and the first stream
is really your own stream from from your
own facebook profile we have a way to
sort of rank your Facebook Likes and
then from your Facebook Likes we can
compute recommended news recommendations
by passing that to being search engine
and getting some results back so then
what we do is we look at your friends
and then we say okay your friendship
information we can do we have a module
that does what's called social strength
ranking and another module that does
user similarity ranking and then we pass
these again through our facebook like
rancor to compute a bunch of different
articles and then we fuse them together
using this ensemble piece here and this
the other I think innovation here is
that we're using this click through to
actually modify the all the way back
towards the beginning and throughout
including the ensemble function how we
are actually work we are actually it
should be the case that the more that we
click on let's say information that
comes from social strength we should
actually start seeing more articles that
arise from social strength you know
produced recommendations and so that's
what we're essentially doing is we're
trying to generate a feedback system at
sort of three different levels that is
responsive to the clicks of users who
are who are getting these news articles
if we just look at one of those boxes
for example this gives you a sense of
its more
complex than we actually originally
thought and so for example how do we
compute the social strength the
subsystem actually takes into account a
variety of different factors including
your relationship status you know who
you've been tagged whose photos you've
been tagged in where you've checked in
you know who's been writing on your wall
geographic proximity what joint groups
do you belong to with your friends and
you know are you what kind of family
relationship might you have with the
front and then we then some these scores
together to get a sense of how strongly
connected you are and so we are actually
this gives you a sense that it's a very
multi-dimensional problem okay the
click-through I guess we've already sort
of mentioned and for example if the user
begins to click more on topics generated
by social strength then we would wait
that stream more aggressively in the
future for future recommendations ok so
our status is that we initially did a
sanity check just to see if it would
make sense to use you know social
information to you know what what did
the results look like and so we passed
these through a Bing and we took the
first five likes from 20 of the best
friends of Mike's and I guess you could
say that he liked the results so that
was that was our initial sanity check
they appeared to be more meaningful but
it was subjective granted and so since
that time we've been implementing
various pieces of the system we don't
have the whole thing built yet but we
hope to have a tech report out within a
week describing how we how we actually
do this and so our focus on sort of the
immediate future is 2x
we build a synthesized the complete
system deploy it on Facebook actually as
a facebook app so people can download
and install it and start getting social
sort of social news news news articles
and in that way that'll actually give us
hopefully some ground truth and we can
get a lot of data out of this so if you
actually can help us and install this
app we'd certainly appreciate it okay
all right so the final topic and I guess
I have like what three to five minutes
to finish up is privacy so i won't go
into great detail we had a publication
at social calm talking about rethinking
anonymity and social networks and the
basic truth is that there are 500,000
facebook applications out there that
want access to your data so that's a and
they all want to access you know they in
different ways and so usually when you
install one of those apps they they ask
you you know can I have access to your
data and you say yes and that's sort of
it yes or no and so we think that there
ought to be a layer between you and some
some protection between you and and all
those you know half a million apps more
than just clicking yes or no that we
should be able to quantitatively
anonymize or describe or filter the
information that's being released and
quantitatively be able to measure how
much information is being sort of leaked
out from your profile and if you look at
some of the previous work on Turk
anonymity and all that it's primarily
designed for these huge health record
information sort of databases or data
sets and you release all that
information at once but in a in a in a
facebook or sort of social network API
you never release all the information
all at once
you make a single query on a specific
user or specific sort of a subset of
users and and you get a small amount of
data back you don't get the whole darn
thing and you don't have to anonymize
the whole darn thing and that's what
some of the prior work has been sort of
focused on so we've developed something
called Q and on and the way that it fits
in in the context of social fusion is
that it's really focusing just on
anonymizing social network information
and so I won't get into too much detail
here I'll just say that what we're
trying to do is come up with a metric so
if you can imagine that this is your
facebook profile or this is this is what
what is really in facebook maybe it
lists your college and your birth and
what movies you like and where you're
currently located okay and someone does
a select on this trying to find movies
from people who are within a certain
location so this is a mobile social
query you can these are all the possible
matches for this and you can release all
this information but what if and the
question that we asked was what if you
wanted to sort of anonymize this and
withhold information selectively how can
you even measure how much that helps you
and so for example in this rather than
releasing every single movie we release
avatar Titanic and terminator okay in
the hopes that that sort of hides us a
little bit and so the the person who
issued this or the facebook app that
issued this query will will get some
information but not the whole not the
whole shebang and so we came up with a
systematic way to ret to evaluate what
is the cost of how hidden is my
information based on all the information
I could have released and so we look at
all the possible combinations that could
result in in this case this release of
data and for example avatar Titanic and
Terminator could be a user a and user be
combined they could have resulted in
hit that would have released this
information that kind of thing and then
in addition to that we examine of all
the different sort of combinations who
is the most common so if a was the most
common and was in every single one of
the possible matches then a would be
compromised without doubt and so the
most common user that up that is sort of
the one who's at most risk of being
exposed if you were to anonymize in this
particular way so we developed a metric
called q so what it does so here's the
original query here's the database
here's our choice for an organization
how do we systematically sort of do this
we say avatar could have come from a C
or D Titanic Coco could have come from a
B or D and we change this from a product
of sums to a sum of products there's a
fast ways to do this and then we measure
the number of distinct terms here the
more terms that we have the more
anonymize we are so that's in our
numerator that's N and then the most
common user is M and in this case the
most common user is B or I think be
appears three times and that's in our
denominator and so q is the ratio of
this and as q increases that means n is
big or M is small and is the number of
different possible sets so that means
you're more anonymized or if M is small
that means you're more anonymize because
the most common user is only in a small
subset of these you know subset and so Q
grows accordingly and so now we have a
way to sort of evaluate for a particular
anonymization what just how effective is
that and therefore Facebook could use
this to develop Q policies and so in
this case if the Q exceeds some
threshold then you know you can choose
to release the data or not or you can
ask you know users to develop sort of
these
these kind of cute policies so I'm just
going to skip this in the interest of
time and basically say we've been
working on trying to build queuing on as
a layer that's between you and the
facebook apps we've tried to preserve
the Facebook API so it looks no
different than a normal so so if your
facebook app queries q and on it looks
no different than quarrying directly on
the Facebook database the only
difference is that in the information
that's returned to the Facebook app is
filtered in some way and and evaluated
using Q&R so we're we just built this
piece o ok so to finish then okay so
that that covers privacy to to sort of
finish a little bit on the
infrastructure that I like to talk about
for this mobile social vision social
fusion we envision as resting on top of
existing cloud platforms like Asher and
Amazon and App Engine these are finding
Amazon's infrastructure as a service
because it's VMs fairly low level we
have even happened Google App Engine as
platforms as a service and we envision
this sort of whole social fusion mobile
cloud computing framework mobile social
cloud as sitting on top of that and that
next generation applications would hook
into and then in addition we envision
that there might have to be some mobile
specific sort of modifications to the
cloud and in fact Microsoft is already
working on some of this there's the Maui
framework which is offloading complexity
between the application and the cloud
and that's very useful for
resource-constrained energy constraint
mobile devices another piece of
infrastructure is what i would call
context where a comp compilation and the
idea here is to make it easier in this
new brave new world of social fusion to
build context where apps and so how can
we make it easier for developers to sort
of develop components of this and so the
basic idea
or the observation is the application is
distributed into many small pieces and
so what we want is for the developer to
very easily be able to sort of compose
what or specify their app and that this
gets compiled by context to our compiler
into numerous small components that are
then assembled together maybe one for
retrieving data one for privatizing that
data one for mining that data and one
for actuated based on that data okay so
let me just conclude that you know what
we've presented is sort of initial we
have not built to this whole vision
we've explored pieces of sort of the
mobile social and sensor vision and I
presented it sort of a how we think it
might look architecture that's layered
cloud-based and tries to integrate
privacy from the get-go and I also
talked about sort of mobile social group
video as well as social news some of our
initial efforts there and also some of
our recently published work on
anonymizing social data using humanoid
so when Mike gets back from his
internship here at MSR I hope is that
that we can start to the building out
the actual pieces of this of this puzzle
okay so that's it any questions yes
yes absolutely right yes yes right right
right yeah human context as an excellent
question human context is incredibly
tricky you know and what we're hoping to
do is with sort of this initial foray
into this area as to extract maybe some
general trends but as you say you know
you may not want to play tennis with
someone even though it seems like you
both like tennis and you know you should
be a good match you know but you're but
in this case it's not right and so it's
an incredibly tricky thing I don't know
how how you know how much progress we
can make because there are always
exceptions or maybe the exception is the
rule and there are no you know trends
that we can actually mine but so we
haven't done enough user studies really
to tell us that there are these general
trends that we can mine and they'll work
seventy percent of the time but that
thirty percent of the time there are all
these small exceptions you know you know
that that caused an incompatibility and
therefore cause the recommendations to
fail you know so our hope is that there
is a 70-percent case you know so
yes yes yeah right yeah differential
privacy and I wish my student was here
to sort of answer that better but as I
understand it's very statistical and and
as you saw here there wasn't really
statistics that are involved here this
is a very bare-bones you know when a
facebook app is asking for your
information they're asking for specific
information and and you know computing
bounds on sort of the statistical noise
that you might inject on the data and so
you can satisfy some some bounds I don't
know if that really applies here you
know I can't say that it does not but
the other thing I would say is that you
know these many times people inject
noise so what does that mean that means
they're perturbing the results so so it
might say instead of avatar you know
Terminator and it might say you know the
Barney movie or something you know and
so that will cause the recommendation
systems to fail downstream those those
those apps and so you can't really it
would be better there I think at least
two major strategies for anonymizing one
is to withhold information the other is
to perturb it where you know and and I
think adding noise is not good for this
kind of these kinds of context where
systems so that would be what I would
say a better approach would be selective
withholding of information you know I
just give less information to the people
rather than giving them deceiving
information you know and and that'll
work in a context of our case but you
know so
exactly the same kind of approach as
differential products and you will fear
an X out of life in their words of this
identifies and therefore if the query
asks for information which is above a
certain thresholds and shouldn't give it
to I mean it was the same approach there
are fewer statistics but it still is
right okay still it's a numeric approach
I don't know if it's a statistical
probabilistic kind of approach right
yeah if you have this system which is
filtering things based on so you know
instead of i walking into a bar yeah i
tell ya my facebook identity so and so
right instead of that you do this queue
and on thing and it says what's almost
like you like to listen to right what
information do you get out of that
having put it through your queue and on
layer that you don't get out of just my
phone saying oh look there's a jukebox
one of my Senate requests because it
seems like a lot of the strength of the
approach is to you know to infer things
about the group dynamics and to know
their 40 because these guys are such a
very good friends happens a different
selection other than emergently
playlists or whatever but if you're
passing your data to disk you and on yep
why don't I just send requests and keep
all of my personal
then you could never get any context
right so I mean you want to sell trade
off right you have to give up something
in order to get something in this case
you're giving up some information to get
some personalization and all we're doing
is saying you choose some subset of the
information to give up right and you get
back something right and one of the
interesting questions actually that this
has thoughts that is spurred is there
are lots of different ways to anonymize
you know up meeting a particular let's
say Q metric or whatever anonymization
threshold you want how do you choose
which is the best one which one gives
the most information content to the
requester right because here you know
half a million Facebook apps some are
games that are maybe not interested in
certain sections of your profile and
others are I don't know some other types
of you know applications and so you can
choose to reveal information that is
more relevant and yet still meets the
anonymity metric so how can you quickly
do this also and scalable do this I
think is one of the interesting
challenges certainly that we ran into
when we were trying to build this into
Facebook is how can we very quickly
compute to this this this anonymity
metric scale ibly and of all the
different combinations a possible and an
autumn is a shin which one gives the
most information to the requesting app
but still preserves the whatever q
threshold you want you're aiming at okay
so that's an interesting question that
we have not actually answered up with
this research
no not just that David and I like these
songs but not how you should put them
together right I mean in order in order
to you say I can choose how much I want
to reveal and get a certain amount of
benefit but in order to get any of that
benefit don't I have to reveal that
these are the 12 people who aren't
currently in a room with and here's all
of our social interaction with each
other so that you can gauge how strong
our time that's a lot well our hope is
that you don't have to reveal all that
information in order to get something
right so you reveal part of that
information and with keanu that's what
we were trying to sort of characterize
but some of the earlier group work which
was separate we were not considering we
were saying let's give us all the
information and we'll do the best that
we can assuming that you gave us divulge
all that information we haven't looked
at the case where if you just divulge
the subset information and then we were
to run sort of these you know social
strength just Assessor rankers and and
other user similarity rankers would that
how effective would that be I think
that's that's partly getting to your
question right we we have not been
assuming yeah you get all that
information and then you can make all
these decisions and then and then you
anonymize after that no it's like you
know we haven't looked at the case where
what if you filter it up front and then
try to run all of this context awareness
will just completely fail you know so
that's a good question it's a great
question okay any other questions all
right well thank you very much enjoyed
it